Speaker 1: Hey, this is very, very interesting.
We are continuing to cover the soft about face
happening on Fox News with regard to the
failed former President Donald Trump's new
candidacy in 2024. And Fox and Friends host Brian
KILMEADE is really at the center of a lot of this
and what is taking place. You know, sometimes
there's this feeling in when you do what i do
that we have to explain a phenomenon in the
absolute most extreme black and white terms.
Fox has completely abandoned Trump and is now
hostile to him and will do anything they can to
prevent him from being president. No, that's not
what happened. What is happening on Fox is that a
number of hosts, Brian KILMEADE is certainly one
of them, have done a soft turn away from Trump,
where it seems pretty clear that even if it's not
about personally what they want, but as their as
their the role that they play on their channel
dictates they want to be friendly to the idea of
a DeSantis candidacy and presidency. If it doesn't
happen, they're not going to completely cut Trump
off such that they have no access to him. If Trump
really is going to be president for another four
years, Fox would be very poorly positioned if
they lost access to Trump because of, you know,
adversarial or antagonistic relationships.
On the other hand, they do want to be there
if indeed someone else takes control of the
Republican Party and ultimately the presidency
like Ron DeSantis. But and so we've seen Brian
KILMEADE do a number of different things,
go out on the street and try to find DeSantis
supporters or play catch with Ron DeSantis
in a total softball interview. As we looked at
yesterday, this sort of thing here is something
that actually did surprise me a little bit, which
is that Brian KILMEADE brings up. Trump now seems
more disciplined than he did at one point, like,
for example, compared to when he had lunch with
white supremacists. It is genuinely surprising
to me that Brian KILMEADE is even willing to
acknowledge that. Take a look at the segment.
Speaker 3: Since he went visit East Palestine,
stopped having lunch with white supremacists and
he has got a very disciplined message. According
to the Emerson poll, he's got 73% approval
rating among Republicans with high school with
high school degrees or below, and he's winning
in almost every state outside California. And
I'll add this to it. It would be interesting if he
does not win Iowa and you go to end and Governor
Sununu gets into New Hampshire and go too soon
and is so popular with winning three terms as
governor there, he could be out and on on a
bit of a roll. This is the most disappointing
I've ever seen him even compared to 2016. If you
see his team, you get text messages every day.
Speaker 1: Okay. So he's a this is the most
disciplined I've seen Trump since he stopped
having lunch with white supremacists. Or as Brian
KILMEADE calls them, supremacists, which is a
different word. But I totally understand what
Brian KILMEADE means. This is the Trump pivot
that, remember, is a conditional pivot. It's a
tentative pivot. It's a sort of depending on what
happens pivot, we'd kind of rather someone other
than Trump be the nominee. But if it is Trump,
we can't totally abandon him because we're going
to want access for the next four years. Now, this
is quite a low bar for a presidential candidate,
right? It's an understatement to call this a low
bar. Trump has never seemed this disciplined,
particularly since he stopped having lunches
with white supremacists. You know, the mainstream
media won't tell you. But guys, it's been months
since Trump last dined with white supremacists,
and we've got to give him credit for that. It is
a stunningly low bar, but it is a little bit
surprising to a degree that Brian KILMEADE
is even talking about the white supremacist
lunch. And it does seem like another one of
those subtle digs. We'd rather someone else.
But I'm also framing this as a positive thing.
We'd rather someone else. But Trump is looking
pretty damn disciplined at this point in time.
Super interesting. And Fox, of course, wants
to host Republican primary debates when they
get going, never mind presidential debates. And
so to some degree, they have to do this. Now,
if we look at the latest polling, what does the
polling say about what's going on? It's really a
mixed bag. There is a new morning consult
poll rated B minus where Trump is winning
over DeSantis by 24. That's a poll that includes
a ton of other people, including Pence and Haley
and Liz Cheney and Abbott and a whole bunch of
different people. There is a new CNN SRS poll,
not as well rated of a poll. That one's a C
plus, C plus B minus is pretty similar. That
one has DeSantis ahead of Trump, even with the
inclusion of Nikki Haley and Mike Pence and Tim
Scott and a bunch of other people. These are
two polls conducted essentially at the same
time by very similarly ranked pollsters with a 26
point difference. Trump plus 24 versus DeSantis
plus two. Very, very interesting. But it cannot
be ignored that the vast majority of these polls,
Public Policy Polling premise University of
North Florida is an exception, and that's
looking specifically at Florida. But in the
national polling, Trump's winning most of them,
even with this outlier CNN poll. So Fox News is
doing what Fox News is most inclined to do. How
do we maintain access for future profitability
and ratings? That is, at the end of the day,
the number one priority. That explains Fox
hosts caught in text messages acknowledging
that all of the election lies were indeed lies,
but saying, our viewers believe something else.
And so we've got to keep going with that narrative
on TV. Expect this to continue. And it is really
wacky stuff. That Brian KILMEADE clip will
be on my YouTube channel, which you can find
at YouTube.com slash David Pakman show.
And a Spanish version of this very story
will be on the Spanish YouTube channel, which you
can find at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.